bonsoir david un contexte tendu donc
pour ce beauvau de la sécurité une prise
de parole attendue du garde des sceaux
face aux syndicats de police comment
s'est déroulée cette réunion
et bien comme on pouvait s y attendre
une ambiance assez électrique un huit
jours seulement après le rassemblement
des forces de l'ordre devant l'assemblée
nationale et le ministre de la justice a
d'ailleurs tout de suite mis les points
sur les i concernant les agissements de
certains syndicats de police durant
cette manifestation écouté jeudi au fond
que l'émotion ne justifiait pas mais
pouvait expliquer un certain nombre de
débordements qui vaut des plus cette
scène où l'on voit la justice va lire
une scène de crime
elle est indigne l'expression qui
consiste à dire que c'est un coup de com
c'est indigne des choses qui ont été
dites sont insupportables pour moi la
liberté syndicale
elle n'est pas totale elle est
essentielle elle est importante il faut
prendre en compte les revendications
qu'elle exprime mais pas au détriment de
la république la république c'est notre
bien commun et pardon pour cette
familiarité mais s'il on dézingue les
institutions de la république
alors on dézingue la république des
maudits rec te ment adressé à fabien
l'amérique le secrétaire national du
syndicat alliance police nationale
auteur de cette fameuse phrase dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure
le problème de la police et la justice
un présent aujourd'hui place beauvau
l'objectif était justement de crever cet
abcès mais après cinq heures de la
discussion le syndicaliste est ressortie
déçue pour lui peu de concret concernant
ses revendications et et notamment
l'allongement à 30 ans de la mesure de
sûreté des condamnés à perpétuité pour
un crime sur un gendarme ou un policier
ou encore la limitation de certaines
réductions de peine et la fin des
rappels à la loi et coupé le signal
donné c'est un discours que leur forme
et qui fait qu'on n'y arrivera pas qu'on
continuera à avoir des drames à avoir
une situation calamiteuse et des
collègues laissé sur le tapis on n'a
toujours pas de signal fort envers les
individus et les agresseurs de policiers
la solution ils ne l'ont pas apporté je
ne vois pas comment ils peuvent la
porter et même son cloche pour les
autres syndicats qui restent sur leur
faim
david même si certains saluent un
échange intéressant
intéressant mais loin d'être
satisfaisant stéphanie même frustrant
selon les mots d'unité sgp police cette
réunion laisse un goût amer pour la
police est pour rappel elle avait pour
but d'afficher l'unité d'améliorer la
collaboration police justice est bien
l'objectif est loin d'être atteint
puisque cette rencontre on peut le dire
a tourné à l'affrontement
la principale revendication est l
exécution des peines on en parlait tout
à l'heure et pour répondre à ces
remontrances et bien le ministre de la
justice s'est appuyée sur des chiffres
sans apporter de réponse claire
dans la globalité des peines qui sont
prononcés dans notre pays je vous ai
donné chiffres la justice est plus dure
peut-être pas aussi dur que vous le
souhaiteriez mais il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle l'indépendance
voilà vous l'aurez compris un peu
d'avancé dans cette discussion le
dialogue semble toujours aussi est
difficile gérald darmanin qui était
présent aux côtés d'eric dupond-moretti
a une nouvelle fois affiché à son
soutien aux forces de l'ordre et a
réaffirmé sa volonté de protéger au
maximum la police en mettant en point
d'orgue la loi sécurité globale mais là
aussi elles c'est loin d'être suffisant
pour les syndicats de police se beauvau
de la sécurité n'a pour l'instant pas
l'effet escompté pour l'exécutif a tout
comme pour les forces de l'ordre merci
david khalifa en direct de la place
beauvau